Now I'm going to show you something. Go
to your Quran Hajj. Chapter 22 of the
Quran. Chapter 22.
Okay. Now that you said that, now I
respect. Now I know you're there's some
hope that God is working in your heart.
Go to chapter 22 and I want you to get
there. Surah Hajj chapter 22.
Okay. When you get there, I want you to
look verses 6 and seven. Six and seven.
Okay, I got it. Okay, read it for me
slowly.
That is because Allah is the truth and
because he gives life to the dead and
because he is over all things competent
and that they may know that the hour is
coming, no doubt about it, and that
Allah will resurrect those in the
graves. Okay, pay attention to what your
Quran said. Allah's the truth. Alaphat,
he gives light to the dead. The hour is
coming. Have no doubt about it. where he
will raise them from the graves. Right?
Yeah. Okay. So, I want you to listen
carefully. On the day of judgment, Allah
will raise the dead from the
graves. He is the truth who gives life
to the dead. Allah raises the dead at
the hour from their graves. Not a
creature, not Jibel, not Muhammad. Allah
at the hour raises the dead from their
graves. He's the truth and he gives
life. So remember that because now I
want to read to you something from the
Gospel of John. I'll read it for you.
You can write it down. John
5:21. John 5:21. Pay attention because
where we're going to go with this. John
5:21. Watch what's going to happen
here. For as the father raises the dead,
this is Jesus speaking. As the father
raises the dead and gives life to them,
even so the son gives life to whom he
will. Quran says Allah gives life to
whom he will. Jesus says, I the son and
the father, we give life to whom we
will. That's number one. John 5:25. John
5:25. Watch here. John
5:25. John 5 verse 25. Just as Jesus
again, pay attention. I'm going to read
it slowly for you. John 5:25, most
assuredly I say to you, the hour is
coming. Don't forget what you read in
Hajj in chapter 22:7. It says, "The hour
is coming. Have no doubt about it. Allah
will raise them from their graves."
Notice what Jesus said. John 5:25, "Most
most assuredly I say to you, the hour is
coming, and now is when the dead will
hear the voice of the Son of God, and
those who hear will live." Jesus says
that hour they're going to hear the
voice of the Son of God, my voice, and
they'll come to life. Oh my goodness.
John 5 28-29. Write it down. John 5:es
28- 29 because I'mma read it for Got it?
Okay, let me read it for you now. John
5:28:29. Pay attention. Do not marvel at
this, for the hour is coming. Hour is
coming which all who are in their graves
will hear his voice. And 25 it says the
voice of the son of God and come forth.
Now final one. John
14:6. John
14:6. Watch what's going to happen here.
John 14:6.
Jesus said to him, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life." The truth, and the
life. No one comes to the father except
through me. Okay? You just read in your
Quran, "Allah is the truth. He gives
life. The hour comes, Allah will raise
them from the graves." Jesus here said,
"I'm the son of God who like the father
gives life to whom I want. I am the
truth and the life and the hour is
coming for those in the grave will hear
my voice, the voice son of God and live.
Why is Jesus speaking as if he's your
God, Allah? Why is he doing what the
Quran says only Allah can do? Oops.
Conveniently, everything that you have
just said is from John. And so if I show
you from Muhammad that John is the
gospel, are you going to say I'm stupid
and I'm sorry for arguing with my
prophet?
Uh, no. Okay. Now, the wait, the Quran
says there's a prophecy of Jesus in the
gospel. Where's that prophecy?
The Quran says there's a prophecy of
Jesus in the Muhammad. I'm sorry.
There's a prophecy of Muhammad in the
gospel. Where's that prophecy?
Oh, the prophecy of Muhammad in the
Gospel. Which one?
[Music]
Uh, which one was it? Isaiah. Yeah,
that's not the gospel. Let me try it
again. Which gospel prophesied Muhammad?
Oh, I don't know that. I know the Old
Testament one. No, no, because your
Quran says chapter 7 verse 157. There's
a prophecy in the Torah and the Gospel.
Do you know what? Which prophecy your
Muslims quote your quote? Which one?
John 14. John 14. John 15, John 16.
where Jesus says, "I will pray the
father will give you another
pariclete." And if you have the halan
halal version of the Quran, guess what
they put in parenthesis? If you go to
7157, do you have
Quran? No. Okay. Can I send you the
link? Because now you're going to
embarrass Muhammad because your prophets
tell me that the prophecy of Muhammad is
in the Gospel of John. The very gospel
you keep attacking. Oh, but that's John.
Oh, but John is good enough to prove
Muhammad was predicted. But when John
proved Jesus is God, oh, but that's
John. John wrote that. You see how
stupid you sound when you argue this way
here? Let me show you. That's Are you
saying that's what Muslim scholars, all
your scholars say that?
Even you, do I need to quote him? Here
you go. Yeah, but that's but Muslim
scholars can say that. That doesn't mean
it's a fact. So then where is the
prophecy again? Where is the prophecy of
Muhammad in the gospel? So you're
embarrassing yourself because in chapter
7 verse 157 it says there's a prophecy
of Muhammad and the gospel that's with
them. What gospel? What prophecy? Or is
the Quran a lie? I just sent it to you.
There you
go. What what do they give as a prophecy
of Muhammad and it's inhan. It says let
me read it. Those who follow the
messenger of the prophet who can neither
read nor write whom they find written
with them in the Torah Deuteronomy 18:15
and the angel gospel John 14:16 oh but
wait didn't you listen to your your
sister your here that's John why you
going to you see when you Muslims talk
like this you make you disgust us and
this is why we hate Muhammad with such a
passion because only a wicked demon
could create such people only a false
prophet like Muhammad could create such
people like you inconsistent, dishonest,
and
wicked. So, John is good enough to show
that Muhammad is prophesied. But when
the same John shows that Jesus claimed
to be God, oh, but that's John. That's
John. Who cares about John? You sure?
You want me to now go to Matthew, Mark,
and Luke and show you that Jesus does
what the Quran says Allah does?
Yes. You sure? Yeah. Okay. Let's go to
chapter 89:es 21- 22 of the Quran.
Chapter 89:es 21- 22 of the Quran.
[Music]
Okay. Let's go. I want you to read for
me. Chapter 89 2122. You read it for me.
Okay. Okay. Read that for me.
Okay.
89:21 says, "No, when the earth has been
leveled, pounded, and crushed."
And 22 says, "And your Lord has come in
the angels rank upon rank." So who's
coming when the last day when the earth
is crushed?
Your Lord and the angels, right?
Yes. And if you read 23, this is the day
of judgment. Because what does it say in
23?
And brought within view the day is held.
That day man will remember, but what
good to him will be the remembrance.
Okay? So don't tell me, don't tap answer
on this. It says, "Your Lord is coming
with the angels at that day." That's the
day of judgment. Okay. Now go to Bakra 2
verse
210. Surah Bakar chapter 2 verse 210.
Okay. Read for me who's coming. 210.
Yep.
Read it.
Do they do they await but the Allah
should come to them in covers of clouds
and the angels as well and the matter is
then decided and to Allah all matters
are returned. So it's talking about the
Jews. So you're waiting for Allah to
come on the shadows of the clouds with
the angels to decide the matter meaning
the day of judgment. So who comes on the
shadows of the clouds with angels?
Allah. You sure? Right. That's what it
says in Matthew 16:27. Guys, I want you
to hear the Quran says Allah is coming
with the angels and he comes with the
shadows of the clouds on the day of
judgment. Okay. Matthew 16:27. Let's see
what Jesus says. Matthew
16:27. Let's read. Pay attention. Watch
what's going to happen here. You said
you want from not John. Let me give you
Matthew, Mark, and Luke. Okay. For the
son of man will come in the glory of his
father with his angels and then he will
reward each according to his works.
Jesus says, "I the son of man come in
the glory of my father with the angels
to repay people according to the Quran."
Is the prophet coming with the angels to
judge?
And the Quran Bakar says Allah. And then
chapter 89 says, "Your Lord, right?"
Yes. But Jesus said, Jesus said, "I the
son of man am coming in the glory of my
father with the angels to repay people
according to what they've done." Oh my
goodness. Matthew 25. That's not a
contradiction.
What is the contradiction? So you
believe Jesus is your God, Allah? No, I
said it's not a contradiction because
how can it not be a contradiction if
Jesus is just a prophet? How does he
come with angels to judge the world when
your Quran says Allah is coming?
Listen, this is one of my questions
because in the Bible, Jesus always
refers to himself as son of man. But
you're you're not listening, sister.
Let's try it again. Jesus is son of man
because he's man. What do you think? We
think he's a ghost like Casper. But let
me repeat, you're not listening. The son
of man is coming in the glory of his
father. So the son of man is the son of
God. The glory of his father with the
angels to judge. Is the Quran in
agreement? Jesus is going to come with
the angels to judge the world.
That's what it says in the Quran. Yes.
So Jesus is coming to judge the world.
So you just proved Jesus is Allah, your
Lord. Thank you.
I didn't say Jesus. I said the Quran,
who's coming with the angels to judge
the world?
The Lord. Yes. And he's coming with the
angels to do what?
To judge the world. And he's coming on
the clouds, right?
Yes. But Jesus said, "I am the son of
man." Because he's man. Nobody thinks
he's Casper the friendly ghost who will
come in the glory of my father with the
angels to judge everyone. Do you believe
that what Jesus said agrees with your
Quran?
Agrees with the Quran. The Quran. Oh my
goodness. My goodness. You're so
demonized. You can't You see it, but you
don't want to say it because now this
proves Muhammad is a son of the devil.
The Quran is clear. Allah your Lord
comes to judge with the angels. Not a
creature, not
an Muhammad, not a prophet. But in
Matthew, Jesus says, "I am the son of
man. I will come in the glory of my
father with my angels and I will judge
the world and repay them." According to
the Quran, Jesus is claiming what only
Allah does.